all right Todd
Todd where are you from originally
where'd you grow up I was born in Philly
moved to the San Fernando Valley in 1979
I was nine years old
grew up in Van Nuys
uh did you get into being a prison guard
prison guard I got in at 35 years old a
little later
I was a mailman before that for about 15
years delivering mail in the valley
in the prison guard job was something to
fit your personality
no I bumped up to one of my buddies
delivering a mail and uh he told me
about it told me about how much money he
makes
so I figured you know deliver a mail by
myself being kind of bored out there
I need some more excitement in my life
and make more money I bet you being a
prison Guardian provides a lot of
excitement a lot of excitement man it
was a circus
how many years you do it oh I did it for
10 years 10 years which which prisons uh
worked up north and Soledad
it's called CTF
it's about the fifth oldest person in
California and then transferred to
Lancaster
both level four maximum
prisons really yeah
what kind of things do you see
you name it seeing all everything from
uh sex to
drugs to everything in the prison it's
much more racial like the hoods and
Crips I mean the Bloods and Crips will
uh
sell up together that it exists in the
hood in in jail they're all the same
yeah they unite because they need the
numbers just in case something jumps off
we're uh versus the other races so it's
the African Americans against the
Mexicans against the that's in Southern
California up north you got the Nortenos
those are Hispanics and then they sell
up with the blacks and then the white
Sereno I mean the Hispanic serenos those
are down south but they're up north and
they sell up at the whites so when
something jumps off you got a crazy ride
up there so you got the Norteno Mexicans
going against the Sereno Mexicans so
it's not all Mexicans they're separate
up North and then
prison gets very violent big time though
you can have a ride over the dumbest
[__] ever somebody bumps into them
without saying sorry but it'll it'll
jump off
all that respect you know they respect
each other and all that they act like
that in there but once somebody crosses
the line over the dumbest [__] it just
jumps off
what kind of things have you seen
oh stabbings guys overdosing off of uh
crystal meth or heroin in a balloon
all kinds of [__] man it's like
it's it's a circus man
doesn't need drugs in yeah drugs uh
guards could sneak them in they have
dentists in there they have doctors in
there they have therapists they have
psychologists they have teachers so
there's a lot of Staff in there that can
get caught up and get manipulated and
get broken down and start bringing in
stuff for these guys from bringing in a
soda to bringing in cell phones to
bringing in heroin and they're owned and
they're done
and with no women around but with no
women around and yeah so if there's a
teacher that
on the street looks like a two she'll
look like a 10 in prison
because these dudes you know
they're animals man
caged up animals man so anything with a
vagina it's going to look great to them
is is the vagina necessary
no oh no they don't need a vagina that's
what I'm saying yeah they don't need a
vagina
yeah if you got any kind of hole
that'll work too man that's what I'm
saying
yeah but the vagina man yeah that's gold
to them it could be a hundred year old
vagina man with yeah
yeah tell me about prison politics so
prison politics goes as uh basically
not like really hanging out with
different races man it's it's sad and
it's sickening man because
it's just a different world in there and
it's not like that
out here
and there's no way that uh
things can get better in there because
do you think the prison system
rehabilitates at all [__] no that
thing's broken it's gonna always be
broken it's just a punishment somebody
it's a money maker man if you really
think about it and break it down
uh older uh gentleman when I first got
hired I asked them like hey man there's
no way that we could stop the drugs
coming in
we have the dogs the sniff cars
sniff visitors we have female guards
that can pat down visitors and we don't
do that
because think about it if you took away
every possible angle from them not to
get drugs in it'd be us versus them
mentality and it'll be all bad so if
they can be deceptive and and get into
[__] that takes that takes a lot of
stress off of us where they're not
concentrating on us all the time
did you have uh
famous uh prisoners at all and like
people not a few people I had El DeBarge
R B singer yeah he was up in Lancaster
and then had a football player that was
in my building for four years Lawrence
Phillips picked for Nebraska he was a
running back he was in my building four
years
good relationship with him and uh he
transferred to Wasco Prison and within a
year he uh choked out his cellmate and
then he actually hung himself so
never really caused problems with us but
he just wouldn't be left alone and do
his time and he wasn't part of the
politics So eventually
something happened in a cell and he had
to choke out his cellmate going to work
every day being surrounded by murderers
and
you know
all these different
Hustlers and
all kinds of guys all day long it's got
to take a toll on your personal life oh
you definitely got to have a strong mind
in advance you got to be a strong minded
individual because yeah man how did it
affect you
um
really didn't affect me man because I
grew up kind of rough and I already knew
the game so when those guys are trying
to hustle me I was already three steps
ahead of them I already knew how did
your childhood prepare you for this uh
drug infested mom did a lot of drugs
didn't really have a lot of boundaries
and structure as a kid ran around with
my friends in the valley every race
Samoans Asians Mexicans blacks and just
rat them up never got into the gang [__]
have friends in the gangs never got
involved with selling dope always worked
hard but I wanted nice things in life so
cruising clubbing chasing females
so it's basically the same thing but the
gang [__] yeah to me to me that's just
stupidest thing ever man over
neighborhoods and and colors and killing
each other nah man
yeah it's crazy how like you're born on
the wrong Street and your your enemies
we had a little click going on where I
lived at and we played against different
neighborhoods and tackle football and
all that but
as as like killing each other
now man color wise nah
not into that
and these guys are creating weapons in
there as well they create weapons in
there any little thing that they can
find their
find their hands on they'll definitely
sharpen it up and
from a toothbrush to getting a little
razor blade on a toothbrush to oh yeah
man they got nothing but time man so
their mind is like thinking of the worst
[__] to do and you've seen guys who have
they've already got a life sentence so
they have nothing to lose they said they
got nothing to lose they've always come
at me like that you know whenever I have
a problem like you can't do [__] to me
and we can do [__] to them like certain
things that we can do to make their life
a little miserable in there take their
TVs from them if their TVs don't belong
to them and so forth that'll hurt them
even though they're not they're never
getting out but watching TV to them
that's a big deal that's their everyday
routine so if you [__] up their routine
it pisses them off and it gets them mad
so they play that game
it's got to be tough on guys who are in
there for things that are not from the
streets not from the the rough lifestyle
of oh definitely definitely yeah if
you're if you grew up with a mom and dad
and you got caught up doing something
kind of weird on the streets and you got
to do hardcore time these dudes will eat
you up in there man they've been going
in the prison system ever since
juveniles and they know the whole game
man and just listen to them talk
yeah you can like the outside world
doesn't know why these guys keep on
going in there and they don't understand
but once you're in there and you watch
and you're like uh no wonder these guys
keep on going back in there they got
their three meals they get their drugs
they got their medication they got all
their boys from the neighborhood it's
like a little Camp just imagine a camp
as you went to Camp when you were in
eighth eight years old all the way up
until you're 50 you're still bumping
into people from the camp and that's how
it is man
you listen to them and you're like
this [__] is wild like damn you know so
and so from this neighborhood oh that's
my cousin's husband you know that and
they all got nicknames they all got akas
in there and they're just listening
you're like what the [__] this is crazy
like no wonder these dudes are all like
this man being out in in the Free World
is probably you get it scares them they
can't survive it man [__] no within a
week they're done they're taking a bad
piss test getting violated they're
committing crimes because they don't
have money for food they can't get a job
out here man
no I've heard a lot of stories of guys
who
just get turned into sexual sexual
objects just by
just because they're there oh you're
talking about imprison yeah
yeah a lot of stuff
a lot of stuff's consensual to me man
not so much raping and all that it's
good Sexual Man especially in California
you're like
we kind of like uh when when a new guy
comes into prison and he has to
celebrate somebody we kind of
accommodate them where they're going to
get along
we usually don't sell up our blood in a
crypt if we have to we will
but we'll sell up somebody that same age
almost if you got a guy doing 90 years
and you got a young kid that's doing two
years we're not going to sell up a 20
year old kid with a 55 year old guy
that's hardcore gang member doing life
yeah that dude's going to manipulate
this young kid and make him his [__] in
there
but what was the most horrifying thing
you've seen
um
I was working on a building where
they're kind of cuckoo and they're all
meds all day and this guy was on the
second tier and those Blood come in from
the second tier dripping all the way
down so me and my partner went up there
walked and they just sent on his bunk
he's just staring at us
and there's blood coming from the bottom
bunk where he was at and he uh he was
hearing voices
so these guys when they have a lot of
money on their books or they could buy
like uh soda they could buy all kinds of
Doritos they could buy all kinds of
things so he took he sold half of the
Coke can
and he grabbed his ball sack and he
actually used half the Coke can to saw
his scrotum and he grabbed one of his
nuts and he flushed it down the toilet
because he said he heard voices and God
told them to do that
and he was just sitting there staring at
us I mean while he was bleeding like
and he lived
yeah but of course I don't know what
happened to that situation but his nut
went down the toilet and I don't know
where it's at now do you think there's
hope I mean is there anything that the
prison system can do to help these guys
once they're done oh it's hard man
because think about it once you have a
record how do you come back on the
street and you fill out application and
you got to hit that check box fell in
if you don't hit that checkbox fell in a
dual background they're gonna find it
anyway so I think the only way they can
really survive is probably know somebody
that maybe owns a business that gives
them a chance
a lot of them want to do right but they
parole and they go right back to their
neighborhoods and they hang around their
boys and what do they do they go down
man start smoking weed and they don't
they can't they don't have the tools man
it's sad because the way they grow up
you know they don't have a dad they
don't have a father figure man dad was
in a gang dad was locked up yeah just
like my my interviews it's like a very
very small percentage of them had
fathers exactly so
I had a good relationship man and the
job was easy for me because it's all
about communicating and talking to them
and these dudes will look at me like man
I wish I had somebody like you in the
neighborhood when I was younger and they
all tripped out on me because I'm white
and they're like
how the [__] do you know about this
lifestyle you being white this and that
because I can relate to all that because
I didn't grow up great but I chose not
to go down that path man yeah so much of
it is is not having role models
to look up to yeah you gotta you gotta
have Role Models man but at the end of
the day you also got to have the will to
cut yourself off from all the bad
friends that you got man and the peer
pressure I was that dude in a car where
everybody's smoking weed get taught a
hit and I'm like nah man I'm good I
don't want to hit come on man stop
acting like a [__] or a [__] pull over
I'm gonna [__] you up right now like how
was that I'm an alpha male man you're
not going to convince me to do anything
that I don't want to do I've done a lot
of dumb [__] as a kid that I wanted to
do
but nobody's going to convince me to do
something nah
will never happen
I had friends in there that I bumped
into from Junior High from high school
that I bumped into at Lancaster It's a
small world man San Fernando Valley is
gigantic so these guys you know go to
different prisons so I saw dudes from
Lancaster that I used to be tight with
in junior high
and then we saw each other and they're
trying to dab me up but I can't dab you
up bro like we're on different sides now
man we used to be cool we used to be
boys but that was 35 years ago
your life took a turn man mine did it
what kind of things go on in in prison
that the general public doesn't
have any idea about
a lot of sex in there man
like coming out of the Academy I would
work graveyard and I'd have my keys in
my pocket I would have to do counts
and you know I got my flashlight yeah
they're going to town man so once I saw
enough of that I said you know what let
me leave my keys out so that [__] can
jingle because I don't want to see that
no more
falls out a female person yeah that's
cool but male prison now I'm good with
that I don't want to see that [__]
so uh the craziest story was I was up
north and they're on lockdown and when
they're on lockdown we sell feed so they
have food ports so I'm serving and I'm
new I'm right at the Academy and they
knew I was new jumpsuits all creased up
boots are all nice and shiny you know
after a few years you don't even care
what you look like in there anyway
so anyway so these dudes are like uh
we're serving them uh bacon French toast
butter and you know that butter on the
on the plates and this butter is real
whipped so I'm passing around the food
trays and these dudes are like hey Co
can I get some butter I'm like bro you
got butter already no man you give me
some more butter and once I gave extra
butter to one of the inmates all of them
saw that [__] and they all started ACO
can you give me some ACL can you give me
some went back to one of my boys that's
been doing it for a while
I said what's up with this butter bro is
this a magical and he looked at me goes
come on man you don't know and I went
don't tell me it's [__] lube and he's
like yep
I'm like [__] maybe I should go back to
the post office man this probably for me
yeah that was like oh [__] I was wild
man
so now you know I'm married so sometimes
when I run out of Vaseline maybe I'll
buy some margarine after store for me my
wife what was the uh after having this
career for a while what did you what
have you learned about Society
[__] I we already knew it was [__] now
it's even more [__]
just the tools man in these hoods in
these neighborhoods man
America don't care about these
neighborhoods man
it's sad yeah it's a lack of Education
lack of opportunity yeah definitely man
these kids that survive these kids that
grow up in those neighborhoods man they
don't know they don't know nothing about
going to college in a 401k they're
trying to put food on the table man
mom's strung out on dope maybe
grandparents no dad no dad of course
maybe grandparents are raising them
grandparents are 80 years old these kids
are running circles and manipulating
their grandparents and running around or
they see their uncles with all the bling
bling driving nice cars all the females
I want that life man I don't be going to
college wasting 10 years of my life
maybe I won't get that I want that [__]
right now it's the gratification man
and that's where the youngins all the
youngsters want
they want their [__] now man they don't
want to put the work in yeah they see
the fast money yeah man I got kids and
[__] God forbid if my kid has to work
eight hours the world's gonna end yeah
it seems like the whole society is the
the younger crowd is about uh
immediate gratification now definitely
they don't want to put the time in man
they want to go to the gym they want to
hang out they want to do other things
man when you know us I didn't go to work
to work eight hours I needed 16 hours I
wanted overtime
I was an overtime horror man I was I
needed money
so yeah the only way I'm gonna get money
is more hours
I'm Jewish man I didn't get Bar Mitzvah
I didn't go to Hebrew school I was going
to be a doctor I wasn't going to be a
lawyer so my mentality was I'm gonna
outwork everybody and hustle so that's
what I did six seven days a week man
worked overtime and I got where I'm at
right now about hard work nobody give me
nothing but why did you quit that life
the job questions yeah two knee
surgeries they punching me out so I was
a liability you miss it at all
I miss it I missed a friendship with my
buddies
but other than that it wears on you 10
years was cool I got in at 35 so
I was the oldest guy like in my class in
the academy everybody else is like 21
22.
but also it's a bad thing when you're
21-22 and all of a sudden you're going
to the academy you got a badge and now
all of a sudden you're a Rambo you think
you're the [__] can't act like that in
there these dudes will get you all day
all night to get you
these are six seven three three hundred
pounds full of muscle
so yeah you can't be trying to act like
you're hard try to punk these inmates
you got to know how to talk
and that was the easy job for me I used
to have the shock haulers coming up to
me talking let me know you know if I can
do this for you do that so it's all
about that of course I'm not going to
give them the keys to
my job
I'm gonna talk to you and we're gonna
work things out but I want certain
things from you and you want certain
things for me so we're going to meet in
the middle
and that's how it works man just like
the inmates
certain inmates I had in my back pocket
because
I want to know where the phones were
where's the her one at
so I'll hook you up I'll give you
certain things not for me from the state
I'll give you an extra lunch so that's
what it's all about man
gotta be a Salesman in there
and I'm pretty good
one thing I do got man get the Gap right
there are there lessons in life and in
regular society that you learned in
there
nah stuff I learned you know on the
streets I bring in with me maybe it
helped me uh perfect it work in there
every day sharpen my craft but I already
had it I was already a Smooth Operator
out on the streets talking talk you know
being a mailman you got to talk to
people customers and interact with
people I'm not an introvert man I'm the
life of the party without doing drugs
you put me with a room with 20 people I
don't know by the time
uh three hours later everybody's gonna
feel like they've known me for a long
time what percentage of these uh the
convicts are are using drugs in the
prison
um
maybe 60 to 70. really 60 70 percent
it helps time go by quick for them sure
they make homemade alcohol in there too
it's called Pruno I don't know if you
heard of it yeah bread apples
yeah strong [__] man so we don't like
that when they're on that because they
become violent right so we usually you
know you've seen rights seen riots up
north yeah
yeah it's wild it's a prison riot like
it's wild man just can't run in there
without winter with a head which are
head cut off
you got to kind of like assess the
situation with your buddies
and don't run in their 100 miles an hour
because they're gonna be you're gonna be
gasped let them get gassed let them be
tired and then you can you know get over
do what you need to do with them
Let It Be gotta let it play out man
you're on a number
even in working in the building man I
would bid on the floor with one other
partner mother partner would be up top
200 inmates in the building
so we're out number 200 technically to
two on the floor one up top so at any
time anything can happen
but you don't think about it man
just like if you hop in a car can't
think about getting a car accident it
can happen
you live life man whatever happens
happens it's meant to be
all right Todd thank you so much for
sharing your story you got it Mark very
interesting appreciate it thanks man